das brandenburger tor
berlins wichtigstes wahrzeichen im
zentrum der deutschen hauptstadt ein
rund 20 meter hohes bauwerk mit zwei
torflügel man seinen seiten der krönende
abschluss der prachtstraße unter den
linden 1 triumph tor das sich
preußenkönig friedrich wilhelm der
zweite ende des achtzehnten jahrhunderts
bauen ließ gekrönt wird es von einer
sechs meter hohen quadriga die vier
pferde werden von der römische
siegesgöttin viktoria gelenkt zuerst war
sie nackt eingewandt bekam sie später
die historikerin zappelte levy hat die
botschaft des bauwerks entschlüsselt
1788 kommt es zu einem wichtigen
ereignissen preußen friedrich wilhelm
der zweite kann einen für ihn sehr
wichtiges bündnis schließen mit
großbritannien und der republik der
niederlande
das möchte er gebührend feiern und baut
sich hier ein triumph tor
der entwurf aus sandstein im
frühklassizistischen stil stammt von
carl gotthard langhans nach dem vorbild
des eingangstores zur akropolis in athen
für die quadriga und viele andere
ausschmückungen war der bildhauer johann
gottfried schadow zuständig
[Musik]
sie zerrte levy hat ein buch über das
brandenburger tor geschrieben und
erklärt den unterschied zum griechischen
vorbild friedrich wilhelm barth seinen
architekten langhans darum möglichst
viel öffnungen des brandenburger tores
zu ermöglichen so dass die durchsicht
natürlich auch den tiergarten und diese
lange achse richtung westen mit diesem
westlichen horizont sieht man sehr schön
hier sehen wir auf dem bild zum beispiel
dieses der menge etwas gedrungener der
architektur der griechischen marmor
architektur
während wir diese diese schöne
zentralperspektive entwickeln konnten
das brandenburger tor zieht jeden tag
besucher aus aller welt an
[Musik]
die pracht des gebäude ist seine höhe
und die figuren an den säulen das ist
wirklich spektakulär
ich fühle mich vor diesem massiven tor
sehr klein
ich bin zum ersten mal in europa und
habe so etwas großartiges noch nie
gesehen
jahrzehntelang war das brandenburger tor
vor allem symbol der deutschen teilung
isoliert im sperrgebiet zwischen dem
ost- und dem westteil berlins erst nach
dem mauerfall wurde es 1989 wieder für
alle zugänglich jetzt ist das symbol der
deutschen einheit
ich denke dadurch dass es so lange zeit
ein
die grenze markiert hat zwischen den
beiden blöcken ost und west hat sich
hier eine ganz ganz besondere emotionale
schranke auch gebildet die ist dann ja
mit dem eisernen vorhang am 22.12 hier
auch gefallen einer der letzten
grenzübergänge den die sed-führung
freigegeben hat wer nach all diesen
eindrücken einen moment der besinnung
braucht
können hierher kommen in den raum der
stille im angrenzenden torhaus diese
stille da drinnen ist sehr faszinierend
und beruhigen
im gegensatz zu hier draußen wo der
ganze tumult ist kommt man da erinnern
wiederzuholen findet man seine innere
mitte das brandenburger tor fasziniert
auch die euromax zuschauer die ihre
aufnahmen geschickt haben
[Musik]
wer das brandenburger tor nach hause
mitnehmen möchte kann sich in einem des
souvenirshops eine mini ausgabe kaufen
als erinnerung an einen ganz besonderen
ort
[Musik]